you
[Music]
what's up players
we're late that's my fault i'm sorry
everybody
i was i was i was in here i was waiting
sitting here waiting
now that we're doing this live
you get a little taste of the h3 lady
laid yeah lateness but
it's not my fault man i was uh
i was uh
on the toilet this morning you guys know
what it is you know what it is is that
ashkenazi jewish that's the flavor you
get with that
do you get any weird like birth def uh
kind of health problems from no
no nothing no i mean uh my my
grandmother has or had she uh passed
away this uh year earlier uh alzheimer's
uh but my grandfather was like
a baldness baldness is the only genetic
disability like you got a pretty healthy
hair well i take medication for it oh
you do yeah i take uh i take both
rogaine and and propecia
right so that you think that really
helps that much uh i think rogaine i
don't know at this point but prophecy
definitely helps i mean it's like
stopped my hairline from receding that's
incredible if that stuff actually works
because i never want to be on the
opposing side of ethan klein the
hairline king yeah well you know
at least i gotta have something i have
tourette's i have chronic diarrhea i've
got ocd you know i'm on i'm on all this
medicine but at least god was like dude
you your hairline is [ __ ]
thank me bro thanks for saying that you
know that means a lot it's [ __ ] like
well you know you take some you you win
so don't don't get too upset you don't
want them you're absorbing the hairlines
of your enemies as they're saying yeah
subreddit i saw that it's true it is
true all my biggest haters have terrible
hairlines yeah it's not good they'll
never cross me or your hair is going to
fall right out that's what i'm saying
like i'm not i'm terrified of that
so what's going on dude how are you it's
been a week since our uh big comeback
episode
how am i i'm i'm pretty good uh
america's falling apart uh but we raised
some money in in my community yeah that
was awesome that was great
what did you guys raise it for how much
do they raise uh we raise the i think a
total at the end is like 166 thousand um
how many abortions is that i i put in
some myself uh it's across multiple
charities i don't have the exact names
of the charities right now because like
they're all
all spread out over uh you know red
states that help like the most
marginalized and underprivileged women
so great job yeah good job i want to do
something similar is plan plan i love
planned parenthood my parent has a lot
of money they're [ __ ] they're they're
kicked up i mean they definitely still
desperately need it in places where
they're you know
being attacked but
the the charities i went after were like
the funds i went after were like very
very
small interesting good for you matt like
left frontera fund is like a good
example of this where they work in the
rio grande valley and they specifically
focus for the most part on undocumented
you know latina uh women
that need abortions in that area and
like can't you know they help with their
transport you know what i mean like
there's a lot of different
things uh leading up to like being able
to get an abortion in a lot of these
states where the state will do
everything they can to stop you from
getting one beyond like just uh you know
giving planned parenthood enough money
which they still do need it
unfortunately
and i love
i love planned parenthood so much when i
was in
college and i was dead broke thank you
sam
well they helped me
out and me
by myself i mean it's just incredible
what they do that our government should
be doing they don't ask questions they
give you all the support in the world um
god bless planned parenthood yeah no
planned parenthood is awesome and a lot
of people don't understand that like
they think that planned parenthood is
just like only doing abortions it's not
true you can go there for regular sdi
testing you can go there for uh to get
your like reproductive health care needs
uh covered you know what i mean and if
you don't have uh any kind of insurance
like they will
not charge you or at least it's like
super cheap it's like i didn't have
insurance at the time and they charged
me like you
know less than a hundred i think it's
free technically and they just ask for a
donation yeah i mean they're they're the
greatest if you if you have insurance
however you know you're then then you
get charged i think pretty sure yeah
whatever the normal amount is but
yeah no it's great planned parenthood is
awesome obviously as is uh all of these
other uh other charities
he's getting to a point where it's
you know
it's it's always been life or death for
a lot of people when it comes to
abortions like you know ectopic
pregnancies and whatnot
but um
you know these states are moving very
fast on well they're moving like in
kentucky right where they're going
it's a full outright ban and anyone that
performs an abortion it's a felony
yeah
um they there's that aspect to it
there's states that are going after iuds
even and like contraceptives
um
in like the iuds the insert the
yeah yeah i mean it's just uh it's
bedlam right now it's whatever sticks
they've realized that you know the
floodgates are open and they can get
yeah they can do whatever they want the
state legislatures and the most damaging
and probably the worst part about it is
that like democrats keep saying just
vote right like just vote just vote for
pro-choice people on the one hand
they're saying that they're still
advocating for henry cuellar who is
literally uh pro-life
guy that's the guy that nancy pelosi was
campaigning for yeah texas 26 yeah going
up against jessica cisneros that
election is gonna happen soon so shouts
out to jessica cisneros um and then also
this fails to recognize that a lot of
these measures are passing through state
legislatures right
and state legislatures are
so severely gerrymandered that like
wisconsin is a great example of this in
wisconsin democrats can win by 10 points
okay so like 60 40 split democrats got
60 of the state's uh votes but it's so
[ __ ] severely gerrymandered that
wisconsin will maintain a super majority
republican that's insane like so they
can overturn election results if they
want to in their state
that's something that they're pushing
for in texas and in many other places
and of course now they can literally
criminalize abortion in the state even
if wisconsin is like no we're blue as
[ __ ] like we just straight up don't want
this they can just be like we don't care
it doesn't seem sustainable you know
it's not also the thing that i don't
understand is like if you're gonna ban
abortion
why are you also banning contraception
just say you don't want women to enjoy
having sex
yeah no that's i mean i saw the guy from
uh
uh what was uh uh ben shapiro's daily
wire whatever
and he was debating someone on abortion
rights and he goes the purpose of the
body is to have babies the purpose of
the body is not to put the pursuit of
shallow sexual gratification i was like
[ __ ] talk about your own [ __ ] body
no actually i love that though because
that's like a major self-report i think
most normal people like the keemstars of
the [ __ ] world who we'll get to in a
little bit probably
and and you know
like the dumb conservative guys like
even they're like no like sex is kind of
fun if you can have it like that's cool
but i think like
it's just
like a freak when you say like sexual
intercourse is actually not for pleasure
but only for hypothetically reproduction
for having babies you shallow [ __ ]
yeah no that you come across like a
[ __ ] freak when you say that so
that's cool like uh that's
not necessarily the way it's like like
guys why are we
they're just such [ __ ] hypocrites i
can't get over
the republicans they are all about small
government until it's literally the most
like you don't have control of your own
body i don't care about anything else
you want to talk about sexual
gratification you want to talk about the
life of the baby whatever at the end of
the day
it's the woman's body and she has
control over her own [ __ ] body
absolutely end a story and a
conversation
yeah
but uh you know using the state
mechanism to hurt marginalized
communities is kind of the whole deal
you know what i mean like whether it be
black people brown people poor people
women gay people you know that's kind of
like what the republican party's uh
ultimate blood is because there is
nothing else to fight for they are in
bipartisan agreement when it comes to
military spending nancy pelosi and the
democratic party just pushed for a 40
billion dollar spending package to
ukraine in a land lease program are you
against that i'm not against it but i do
believe that uh it should be more
measured than the way that we're
currently operating where we're just
like literally flooding the market with
guns as many guns as possible that's
what's going on basically yeah because
historic and they openly admit they
don't know where the guns are going
brave muhaji were worse you know i mean
shout out to the brave muhajeebs or what
was their name brave mujahideen yeah um
so
so there's a part of that uh there's cia
training uh there are reactionary groups
and then there's also a legitimate on
the other side from the ukrainian side
there's a legitimate interest in like
you know stopping russians from [ __ ]
brutally murdering their citizens and
leveling their cities so
um as is the case with uh with most of
these like uh you know color revolutions
or or uh or or any kind of movement like
the american state department and the
military industrial complexes interests
are completely aligned with the genuine
legitimate understandable desire of
emancipation from ukrainian people
but the people that are getting the bag
are still the military industrial
complex in the circumstance and i think
the long-term consequences of of this is
going to be really damaging for ukraine
so why is it that they aren't more
particular i mean it's not like ukraine
is picky with the aid they receive why
why don't they be more targeted with the
in a constructive way
i mean big daddy america is giving them
guns and they desperately want it but
you're saying he's asking for it you're
saying we're the mistake we're making in
the ukrainian aid situation just
flooding the market with guns like
ideally what would your
support for ukraine look like i think
guns leading up to a certain point is
obviously going to give an upper hand a
significant upper hand to ukraine when
you say guns you're talking about like
javelin missiles small arms javelin
missiles uh yeah like weaponry in
general yeah and it did it [ __ ] is is
whipping yeah apparently those javelins
make a huge yeah like when they took
down moskva i was like holy [ __ ] that's
like that's legitimately an incredibly
impressive feat to be able to take down
a k like a a massive ship oh yeah
and the ukrainians are beasts man those
guys are brave as hell those are those
they are some brave mohad muhajibs down
there no well i mean dude
there's there's so much this is like a
very complex issue obviously like uh i
mean i have a lot of i have friends in
ukraine i have people who have like
immediate family members in ukraine uh
we've raised a lot of money for ukraine
in my community i think we're raising
around
227 230 000 for uh refugee aid
specifically the lend lease program is
40 billion dollars over the course of
multiple years right
but then
the uh
unfortunate thing is that
um
what the [ __ ] sorry i just thought
i
my bad uh that what were you looking at
what was dan is something dan did no
there was just someone that like rolled
up it's fine that nothing hey
hey dan you you talk to whoever was back
there
i'm just no no um
sorry the the lend lease program
i think a a tiny fraction of that is
actually going to like refugee aid like
these people need food they need they
need resettlement there's not enough
humanitarian aid yeah i i think that
like
you know i know that zielinski's asking
for guns and whatnot but like what the
people need is a little bit beyond just
like uh being able to fight
for i guess the logic is you got to
uh beat the russians first yeah
yeah you could do both though with 40
billion dollars oh the thing i was going
to say yeah well the thing i was going
to say is like i think the the aid
should
exclusively revolve around an uh a
the aid to ukraine
should be for them to have as much
leverage as possible like maximum
leverage and not necessarily the entire
like purging of the russian military
because that's extending the conflict
which even like the democratic
representative seth moulton openly
admitted on fox news is not even
necessarily just for like ukrainian
liberation but actually to undermine
russia's power like its military power
and it's been very successful it's been
more successful than the way that
analysts predicted it even where um at
this stage it's like
uh you know they russia's military power
is laughable you know yeah yeah they're
getting whipped around they've lost like
25 of their capabilities
by a country that barely had a standing
military in 2014 you know what i mean
like a country that literally uh got
incredible amounts of training and aid
over the course of the past you know
almost 10 years and was able to put up a
actual strong opposition yeah to this
invading force
um
but i feel like there is no western
leader at the moment uh whether it be
boris johnson or uh anyone in the united
states that's like we need to stop the
war like we need to push for some kind
of you think we're not pushing
off no i don't think we are at all but
do you think that's even an option it
seems like peace isn't really an option
it's maybe it's propaganda but from what
i've been hearing putin is basically oh
there's always not gonna stop until
he at least takes a huge chunk
because he's going to be humiliated if
he leaves with nothing oh for sure what
why would the ukrainians give them
when they're winning so there was a well
there's no winning that's the that's the
problem right like when you they're
fighting all the time there's no winning
you you still end up losing of course
but i think they have the upper hand
right now in terms of just like
russia is losing more
every day i feel like yeah but then
there at what cost is the question and i
think like leveling entire cities for
ukraine
and and you know
thousands of citizens dying in the
course of this is in my opinion
not justifiable i wanted i wanted to
come to an end or at least i want like a
peaceful solution like the 15-point
negotiation plan that they were talking
about in turkey that is like completely
thrown out now in the aftermath of like
boris johnson's visit i think that's
when it corresponded to that 15-point
negotiation plan like being dropped
immediately and i think zielinski
actually did a really good job there
where he managed it perfectly and
literally was like
we're not going to have a conversation
about crimea we're going to table that
for the next 15 years
because you know we need to make uh
we're a democracy we can't
uh have
um we can't just like
uh unilaterally
say okay we're gonna demilitarize
according to your wishes um and they
also wanted security assurances from the
uk not similar to like article five but
at least some level of security
assurances from the uk and other like
european countries and they were like no
we're not going to give you security
assurances
uh and and i think it just seems like
they just wanna they wanna fight till
every last ukrainian like they wanna
they wanna make sure
that uh they completely destroy russia's
military i mean you're talking about
western powers ukrainians and ukrainians
wanted to like i mean yes of course
their nation building project larger
don't you think putin is uh i mean maybe
you're right i don't know i mean i see i
see what you're saying where western
leaders are like no let's let them fight
it out yeah here's what putin doesn't
seem that eager
to settle i agree i actually agree with
you um i don't know uh i was wrong in
the beginning of the invasion like my
analysis was correct and the premises
that i launched off my now uh my my my
prediction were correct that like russia
would have a really hard time like
overtaking ukraine if it would be
impossible to occupy a country with 44
million that's a big drama for you yeah
i know um
uh you said that uh
the russians will never invade it's so
stupid it's so it is but you're seeing
why right like you're you're noticing
exactly why yeah i said it was [ __ ]
stupid and it was and it still is it's
violent it's barbaric it's stupid
and
basically
now
what i'm
what i've been saying is is just
i i want like some kind of uh some kind
of peaceful negotiation to
come out of this so that uh the the
the because the continuation of this war
is only going to make it worse for
everyone involved
i hope putin just [ __ ] croaks or
something man
that would be the best outcome that
would be the most desirable i hope he
just [ __ ] takes a trip to the lake
you know what i'm saying i mean i don't
know what's gonna happen but you know
who knows okay such a piece of [ __ ] well
anyway
die
thank you wendy williams is on the same
page as me
yeah
i want to give a quick shout out to
teddyfresh.com
the new collection is out
it's live now teddyfish.com
thank you thank you this is the hoodie
i'm wearing hassan anything you want in
here
um i'll let you know i mean yeah let me
know thank you thank you
the best stuff's been for women lately
look at this
sorry bro
i don't think the three xl there's
always there's that's always the case
bro that's always the case i could try
to get you in that 3xl i'd like to see
what that would look like
all the all the best stuff is always for
for the ladies yeah
oh i have those i have the the handcuffs
oh the necklace yeah the necklace
doesn't fit me but the but the bracelets
do oh it doesn't wait is that kai
wait go back to the bracelet go back to
the bracelet on the right no no no no no
oh my god
wait wait i don't think so it's just a
model am i crazy my eyesight is terrible
no wait
hold on he's he's in other stuff that is
kai
that's my very good friend he's a
designer himself
yeah
so here here
yeah i think he told me about this he
said he worked with you yep that's kai
oh [ __ ] you know him yeah yeah that's a
really good
uh hbo's uh he was on like a fashion
show on hbo he's a he's a young designer
oh well he's also oh yeah kai here's his
mom here's his name
shout out kai everybody it's so funny
we love it
anyway teddyfish.com check it out thank
you
shout out kai
also a little plug maybe you want to
join us this saturday are you busy uh
most likely yes but your you guys are
going to be
fighting yeah
so we're doing a live stream for
members only at 3 p.m we're going to be
live watching abs fight
join us
so also so anyway let's get into it
shout out philly d you know we have a
running
gag with philly d where i am in leading
i've got to be on the top five of all
time the led thumbnails and so he's i
feel like he's trying to pit us together
here but you ever you have a
a long runway uh over me obviously i've
only in the last like year or two he
started click baiting with my face on it
you've been making a lot though you got
me sweating a little bit we're gonna
have to get it we're gonna have to get
an updated tally here so i have some i
did a quick count oh thank god uh right
before the show
in the last eight months
ethan has been in ten thumbnails oh [ __ ]
you're gonna you don't have more than
that for no i don't think so
hassan has been in 12.
let's go
let's go dude [ __ ] yeah billy deep come
on bro we you said we were brett i
thought we were friends now you put now
you beat me by two you gotta hold his
elbow
but hold on lifetime i gotta i mean
lifetime doesn't yeah lifetime is not
even yeah i mean i was i was
i'm not surprised though you've been
you've been charting man you've been
charting hard it's not a good thing
usually it's a funny thing you know so
shout out philly d okay philly can i get
some more thumbnails please i gotta get
more outrageous here
yeah just get just get cancelled a bunch
and and you know you'll see i gotta i
gotta wonder if that's worth it yeah no
it's not it's literally not worth it
it's i can tell you and i know you know
as well um beginning of getting
cancelled though
you know who's trying to cancel me right
now oh yeah my our favorite our yeah
keemstar baby
is this his first time trying to
target you in this way i mean obviously
he's done like a million things on
twitter like he was like loki the person
behind the american deserved 911 push
like he was the one who like got that a
lot of like fox news exec i mean uh
fox's producers should probably like
watch him or a lot of like oh god
nazis and stuff yeah yeah follow him and
then they were hyping it up and then fox
and his producers uh
paid attention to it and it was on
tucker carlson and whatnot but
he's been doing it like he's been he's
been at it for a while which is always
funny because he'll always be like this
hassan guy
and i'm like
yeah it's like he doesn't know you yeah
yeah i don't even know who this hassan
guy is
well and he's accusing of being racist
and he misspelled racists of course he's
like many people have pointed out and he
has yet to update it he's really
neurotic
ethan
he's dyslexic no i don't know but he's
so stupid like well he's damaged i mean
dyslexia is not is not the beginning of
his problems what he's what the problems
that he has stem from
you know being unloved but daddy
absolutely
let me see what kind of view count we're
working with like well i think he
actually did pretty good
because
a lot of your fans i think uh went there
to downvote it which we love
but um
let's see here i want to watch it
because i haven't actually i tried to
watch it last night i was like i can't
[ __ ] do this i think the down votes
are actually because of the aspect ratio
because if you look at the comments even
yeah
yeah yeah
clown oh 300 000 not that good yeah no
he uploaded in
9x16 he did it backwards i love that
look at this i love that
people are saying he uploaded the
snapchat version to youtube yeah he's a
game changer dude i don't know what you
guys you guys are just hating on my man
okay he is so he's so
brilliant what the [ __ ] is this like
you're you're a [ __ ] 40 year old guy
who's like covering you know little
teeny bopper [ __ ] uh in your drama alert
emilio is in trouble this week anybody
still can't [ __ ] figure this part out
it's like come on bro ah it's awesome so
let's watch
i mean not the whole thing it started
like no i think my part starts at like
and we don't even need to watch the
whole thing
unless you want to
i think my parts are like five minutes
or something or like yeah five minutes
here we go right after yeah yeah
bro i gotta break it to you i'm so sorry
what's up what's going on
i got a [ __ ]
dropped
okay grumpy
what do we do then what do you want it's
a live show there's nothing to do you
just gotta float it i mean i could keep
it going yeah float it i i do load it
and i'll float it i do i do live streams
you know
i don't i guys i this is not i'm not
happy about this i have to do it i'm
literally
i don't know what's going on man okay
well i'll give you guys the background
on this uh while while ethan is pooping
and here i can i can manage it from over
here right wait i want to watch it uh
well well you're leaving i mean you
gotta give us
we're not gonna watch it we're not gonna
watch it without you oh my god here i go
i got i got something we can fill the
time with actually what do you got
check this out
ian you got my my screen right
what is that
okay so this is your streaming setup as
i'm sure you're well familiar with
uh-huh you see this right here
uh-huh most prominent thing on your wall
yeah do you know where that came from
wait that photo once upon a time in los
angeles yeah
do you have do you yeah
so that's grand theft auto role play
right this is grand theft auto role play
but where did it come from
like what do you mean like where'd you
get it
oh my p.o box right a fan sent it to you
uh-huh did you know that that fan is in
this room right now
wait what
sam
dan you're embarrassing me i am
embarrassing oh my god i didn't want to
seriously isn't that [ __ ] crazy
coincidence oh my god no i did not know
that at all that's incredible it was way
before i was working here
she's like i don't like you anymore
don't worry you're [ __ ] really funny
but
thank you thank you dan
she thought it was cringe to tell you
but i thought it was no it's not cringe
at all that's awesome that is so sick
that's like you know it's one of my
favorite uh pieces of art i have it
literally right next to it it's the most
prominent thing in the frame i couldn't
believe it yeah
wow you made that gta
you were a gta you were a grand theft
auto role play fan
we i watched it every day oh my god i
loved it okay that is embarrassing
i'll i'll admit
that that's definitely embarrassing
you're under lockdown
you know
right right yeah no i i feel you i feel
you that's that's crazy um yeah i uh i
was going to bring back uh
donny my character on grand theft auto
role play or potentially go back to role
play for like one day at least if i
reach 200k but we didn't so on the
abortion charities so
sorry everybody
anyway um how long does ethan's poops uh
normally like you guys time it you know
like
not too long five five minutes or so
yesterday's it was pretty long
it was ten minutes yesterday ten minutes
oh jesus oh lord okay
yeah
all right well we'll vamp okay well here
uh
i'll just give like a little bit of a
background on this thing uh i think
right should we not do that while people
are the keem thing no go for it yeah
okay so
so gideon who for those of you who don't
know is a uh he's a tick-tock comedian
he does like some prank stuff you know
he goes to best buy and like you know
and also some of the people that go
there you know he has like some funny
sketches
funny skits he has some annoying ones
whatever right um
ultimately uh i i did not know anything
about him originally but then like there
was the whole saga with pokeman which
now the beef has been settled and i
thought it was actually really amicable
and very nice for both parties to you
know
actually reach across the aisle and have
a conversation with one another um
so i'm not going to parse through that
too much but that was the original that
was the first time i ever heard about
him
and then afterwards uh he recently had a
youtube video where he went to the
most racist town in america now this was
some of you might have remember some of
you might remember this video i reacted
to it as well uh it was uh
a dude who with a black lives matter
sign went to uh one of the
one of the most racist towns in america
basically and everyone was like
screaming at him
um uh the the town itself is actually in
uh where is it in harrison arc
i was going to say arkansas which is
what the inside joke on my stream
arkansas
which should be called arkansas yeah
and
and uh you know some other youtubers
have been there since then and they've
like kind of whitewashed it or basically
have said like oh it's not actually that
racist and this is a very complicated
and complex this is a very
complicated subject to cover right
because it's
it's not as uh as simple as like oh
you know this person is going to be
racist to you if you go there if you're
a black person they're going to be
racist to your face or anything like
that i mean uh white supremacy is is
largely systemic
and and uh often does not
conduct itself in a in a
person-to-person individual uh capacity
which americans usually misunderstand
and think like oh no racism is when
someone calls a black person the n-word
and and nothing else right
and as a political commentator my job is
to educate people on on you know
what that's actually like
and i think like
there's a little bit of a
miscommunication there but gideon took
offense to what i was saying and and
thought i was uh patronizing him as a as
a black person who grew up in america he
was like i understand racism
and you are
you're over here telling me what racism
is like and worrisome is not like i mean
he ended up talking to some people there
uh who were of course not racist which i
you know understand i there are plenty
of awesome people living in red states
and in you know even racist towns like
this obviously you know just regular
working-class people
um and then he ended up talking to a
klansman
who lived right next door to the actual
grand wizard of the kkk
and the dude is like very openly like
i'm i'm you know he's like i'm not a
segregationist but i'm a separationist
you know and i thought it was actually
really interesting i like that
conversation because i'm fascinated by
[ __ ] you know uh weirdo hogs like
that right
um
and in that conversation like i i felt
like it was a little bit of a sanitation
happening there but
um
but he didn't appreciate my analysis on
it i guess when i was like describing or
talking to my own audience about
you know how uh white supremacist
movements oftentimes will
uh will will adopt you know white power
as a reactionary movement to black power
all lives matter as a reactionary
movement to black lives matter to like
take away from the subject matter itself
and also to make their uh underlying
nefarious agenda seem more approachable
and more palatable so they're very good
at pr is basically what i'm saying like
race people are very good at doing pr
they will never admit that they're
racist
and they'll find like numerous ways to
to deflect away from the uh you know
underlying message but this guy was
openly saying like i'm not a
segregationist i'm a separationist and i
was like well that's that's segregation
you know separate but equal right the
entire thing
um
so talking about that sort of stuff i
think he he just did not appreciate that
and and then keemstar of course was like
oh this is a great opportunity because
you know he is the
i mean he knows he knows racism i mean
he's the least racist man in america
yeah no he has a doctorate in racism
like he is by doing it by doing so such
incredible amounts of racism all the
time
uh he is probably the most knowledgeable
person on racism so he he uses an
opportunity to be like haha hassan is
racist
or
uh i guess would it how do you say that
racist ross
yeah
um
so you know that's but i don't want to
watch any of it before ethan gets here
but but that's basically short and sweet
of it yeah that makes sense and and
i'm going to talk to jillian
if you've spoken to him yeah well i dm'd
him actually even before any of this
stuff happened because i was like
because he's he's reached out to me
before
uh for something unrelated back in the
day i think it was like
i think it was like to to
set up like a boxing thing or something
and um i was like no i'm not gonna fight
you but hey you know i hope you do find
someone who wants to that's great
and i i dm'd him and i was like hey uh
you know
love to talk to you like i saw some
snippets of your like reaction to me
reacting to your video
um you know i wanna you know if there's
anything you need to you need me to
clarify like i'd love to do that
it was like sure um i'm
totally down you know when do you want
to talk and and we're supposed to talk
on saturday but
he also does seem to
um i mean he he seems like he's
appreciating all the people who would be
like yeah hassan is a racist person
so i don't know maybe he'll see how that
goes
yeah he said he said it's giving white
savior and i was like i'm not you know
i am white but uh definitely not a white
savior
um anyway so that's that's what's uh
that's what's happening on the on the
keemstar ethan or not ethan sorry
keemstar judy and uh hassan [ __ ] saga
we uh we got a update from ethan in our
group chat and he said still pooping
getting close to done eta two minutes
we got two minute warning
okay
all right i mean if you want we could
start watching it then is he watching it
in there
just tell him to start watching in there
ethan are you watching on the stream
right now you you got us up on your
phone well there's probably a delay oh
that's true just like play the video on
his
you know oh right maybe he can just send
us his reactions uh via text message
yeah and like his commentary and yeah
so ethan in 30 seconds when you get that
let us know if that sounds like a good
idea
song you're gone yeah i see that
a lot happening right now
live show baby
yeah it happens
[Music]
hashan pecker
[Music]
all right
so was it the 10 billion dollar set
this one to happen if we got 11.
i know it's the one it's the additional
1 billion that counts the most usually
yeah
we have the funds for it we can invest
in that
[Music]
that's right
look at that
it's like a liminal space
yeah well right as you got out of the
bathroom i don't know
no no no
no no we were fine i was just giving
about it's but we're back i was giving
background information on like what
happened
i don't know if you were watching or not
but people hate when i do this
is that [ __ ] up it's bad
because it's like it's happening so much
that my [ __ ] is being traumatized do
you know what i'm saying hassan i i
don't know you will someday i i i don't
know i got like pretty good constitution
like i
you know i grew up eating like [ __ ]
like pigeon meat and [ __ ] you know and i
mean like turkish street food so i don't
know i think like
i mean you know
you're gonna [ __ ] yourself someday i
know it
yeah i i hope not but no it's coming
it's good you think you're better than
me
no i i don't think that i think it's
pretty normal for me to not [ __ ] myself
i think it's just oh i pooped so you
think everyone's better than me um
on the on the [ __ ] yourself spectrum
i guess if you you guys never you guys
never had like a chronic diarrhea like
this
no i have of course yeah no i mean i
have diarrhea sometimes you are better
than you yours ethan unquestionably
excuse me
i'm willing to go i don't let him say
that
my intestines [ __ ] rock your
intestines dude have you ever [ __ ] pesto
you know what i need a fecal transplant
yeah can i get some of your [ __ ] bro
sure if you want i can give it to you
give you like a pill or something and
you put it up your ass oh i see i
thought they just
turkey based your [ __ ] with other
people's [ __ ] oh jesus christ okay
because the pills not enough they take
it all they just they do a you know what
i mean what did you eat last night
i know it yeah no it wasn't i didn't do
a good thing last night
i just had a frozen pizza
like a hole
but that's it that's all it takes now
what are you doing
eat clean did you unfreeze it first at
least
yes i cooked it and i added a shitload
of cheese and olives on that well there
you go dude you are literally the
wealthiest person that still eats frozen
pizzas
there's nothing wrong with frozen or if
you want pizza why don't you just like
order it i don't think that would be
better for me i think this are you
lactose intolerant i don't know i i
don't i didn't think so but there's
something happening on those whenever i
eat pizza now where it's just like
[ __ ] your whole week [ __ ]
that's good it's a good motivator to not
eat pizza
yeah i think i've i think i've
successfully uh connected the dots on
that one yeah i would just stop eating
pizza i think i don't know it's like
like eel pizza experience for me
for me personally like when i [ __ ]
when i you know break the seal a little
bit on the pizza thing or cookies it's
like very hard to recover yeah i'm
constantly looking so good and it's like
damn right i had cookies when i had
covered
okay because i was like i'm gonna treat
myself you know i'm a binge eater too
i'm an emotional eater stress eater all
that
uh and i and i ordered some cookies from
this [ __ ] place and these are like
thick they're chewy but they're like
thick they're like this thick okay one
of them had like nutella in it the omfg
cookie
the other one was like an oreo cookie
and and i ordered i ordered a dozen and
i immediately gave like seven to my
brother's girlfriend because i was like
i will eat all of these like you need to
get these [ __ ] away from me right
thick
and then the rest of it i had
and i've been literally thinking about
it it was the day it was the day that
roe v wade was overturned or at least
where were you when you ordered it yeah
i just remember it from that you know
significant uh thing well treat yourself
man have a [ __ ] cookie for christ's
sake i didn't i had well i didn't have
one cookie i had like four but you
haven't had any since then i haven't had
any since then but i think about it all
the time kind of cookie it's literally
it's like it's how i am it's like crack
it's just a [ __ ] cookie sometimes
they'll see a random cookie that like
reminds me of that cookie and i start
getting sweats like i'm really cookie
monster i think about cooking i should
call her you see a picture of like an
oreo outside you go i should call her
yeah no literally i mean not just get it
just eat the cookie man
no i can't do it just eat the [ __ ]
cookie you're encouraging me to do it
right now um it's one cookie the men's
house no i didn't i clearly can't stop
that's my point though is like it's not
one cookie so i just use substitutes i
had a cookie last night i had a quest a
protein cookie it doesn't taste anything
like the real thing a question an
oppression cooking
yeah i mean it's like 250 calories it's
got a decent amount of protein in it but
like it tricks my brain into thinking
like mmm
what is it cookie
hassan i i've i eat those too i keep
them in my fridge but those look at
these are nice these are nice they look
good but they're not but it's like no in
reality it's 250 calories it's almost
the same as
or if not more than the the the rate
the cookies that i'm having are like 300
calories but the problem is 50 calorie
difference
no no it's not just the calorie
difference so the protein doesn't taste
as good i can stop at one
but if it's like is it it's the protein
the carbs the sugar has good protein
yeah it is good product we gotta you
always gotta get probably a real cookie
has like around seven grams probably
maybe even less than that this one is
15. dude be real those taste like [ __ ]
like no that's why yeah
that's why that's why because i can see
you like it tastes like [ __ ] you could
stomp yourself yeah
straight up that's interesting the main
reason like it doesn't taste good but it
still fills that like void that i the
problem i have now is like when i was
living
by myself
i
could
just not buy [ __ ] i didn't want to eat
and that was no problem now i have two
kids oh and a wife who are like skinny
obviously my kids are young but like
skinny legends he's a kid so he's always
snacking juice and crackers and all this
great stuff and my wife is a sweet tooth
so these pizzas they were bought for
theodore
they were tiny little pizzas and so i
made two of them that's not easy that's
so i thought that's just it's all
temptation in my house i know i know
what that's like i eat all of theodor's
food by the way
whenever we get them corn dogs and
little pizzas and i go [ __ ] eating
thank you whenever my parents are
visiting and they're like they're coming
uh
actually and they're coming tomorrow um
whenever they're visiting it's the
absolute worst and they come and they
stay for like
three four five months they're not
strict like you obviously they're of
course they're not strict at all they
get down with to tempt you
well first of all they're all they're
you know my whole family's obese i've
talked about this before i'm the only
one in my family that's actually been
able to like without a gastric bypass
surgery uh you know lose all this weight
and like maintain that
um and it's rigorous it's uh it's you
know it's a regimen that i need to
follow at all times
uh which i don't have a problem with you
know i eat like you know fun things that
i enjoy eating that i don't have a
problem with it all but when they come
in they're like they want to have pizza
they want to have
my dad has he had diabetes his whole
life so now he is a huge sweet tooth
after his gastric bypass and he's always
like he's always like sneaking in
pastries in the [ __ ] house so wait he
had a beard he had a gastric bypass did
he did he lose his diabetes status yeah
he lost his diabetes status working on
getting it back
pretty much yeah he's been he's doing
all right though my brother probably
gave more weight than my dad did in the
aftermath so i'm actually the opposite
i'm the only obese person in my family
everyone else is skinny that's
accomplishment yeah thank you so we both
have achieved
something special let's stick my male
behavior yeah we follow our own path
yeah exactly
so
you know it's just hard it's hard but
it's it's whatever you know i i
i i manage
i try my best good for you man no you're
good you're healthy
yeah good god bless but you know who's a
[ __ ] little but speaking of uh
so this guy's got no [ __ ] hair
no he used to be fat he actually lost a
lot of weight i'll give him that he's
cause he runs right doesn't he he's why
because it
oh my god that's me in the in the gucci
shirt
it looks like it's like a onesie they've
made it for for cookie monster well cam
was working fast he did what he could
yeah
i mean it was pretty big on me too so it
makes sense yeah that's me have you worn
that gucci shirt yet since no
um i can't wear it here because green
screen uh yeah it has greens on it i
really wanted to but i can't it really
limits my wardrobe these damn greens
yeah i do like the color green so um i
mean i haven't had like an opportunity i
probably i'll probably wear it soon
yeah i don't really wear a lot of like
collared shirts on stream but you know i
wear them on special occasions
i don't get that by the way it's like oh
you're throwing a collar and now you're
fancy it's just a [ __ ] shirt with a
little flap of fabric no i don't get the
collared shirt theory i don't i don't
make the rules that's what that means no
i know but i'm just saying like oh i'd
be like or ela does that to me she's
like you put put on a collared shirt
yeah no you put on a collared shirt
you're like what are you talking about
this shirt's the same as that one no
you're going to watch polo in polo
grounds
i got some scratchy
collared shirts you know it doesn't
matter you put a collar on it's over
it's it's a totally different ball game
anyway so that's why by the way is
freaking out because you guys mentioned
the green screen uh just to clarify
there is no green screen that is a 10
billion dollar set yeah of course
there's no green screen i just like to
throw people turn off the green screen
show them
turn it off oh
god what do you we don't have the
technology dude turn it off we would
have to we just did there is no green
screen yeah we have to comp in a fake
green screen behind you in real time all
right so yeah
oh they did it wait oh my gosh people
always wondering what's the deal with
the fake desks so
wait you're why is your shoulder missing
i don't know because it's not keyed out
anymore
i don't know how they it overlaps go to
hassan's camera
wait what's that fun that's how it works
there it is
this looks like a hostage video
i just realized like
totally
yeah
all right anyway
forget you saw here's the men in black
uh memory zapper
well actually we tricked them
successfully it's kind of impressive
that you guys were able to put the green
screen up so quickly yep well we're
getting a lot of flack from spending so
much money on what we needed to
never let them know what's next
all right you want to watch this big
dumb fat unlovable idiot uh sure
yeah so keemstar tried to cancel hassan
pathetically here it is tell you this
story okay
gideon all right gideon went to the most
racist town in america he uploaded this
video four days ago i went to the most
racist town in america the video has
popped off getting over six million
views now here's the thing when gideon
went to this town the most racist town
in america obviously is the black man
right he didn't really get a lot of hate
he didn't get a lot of racism he
actually talked to people he had good
conversations the by the way
keemstar has been riding gideon's dick
ever since the pokemon thing yeah he
picks out like rising stars to try to
leach onto yeah and like no no he's
doing that right now yeah he kissed
their ass and just tries to become
relevant and you know it's just it's
what he does with with certain people
and it really works it's kind of weird
but yeah
the thing is uh
aside from that though like what he's
saying here is pretty funny it's like
like what do you
what do you expect to happen like do you
think that like just random people in
this like 13 000 population town are
just going to be like oh i'm there's a
black man pull out the glitch yo no no
they're like normal people living there
bro like that's not how racism works
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
of course there's like anti-racist
people that live there you know what i
mean like obviously what the [ __ ] i
don't know what i guess i haven't seen
jillian's video so i don't know what the
most racist town in america
no like there is i think it's like
pretty
the first conversation that he has with
uh a waitress at the restaurant they go
to is like pretty informative where
she's like i'm a normal person i'm not
racist but there's some [ __ ] freaks
that live in the town next door at zinc
okay that's where the klansmen are all
right
and and that's it that's like that's the
whole point like they they were able to
historically establish there and and
they pushed them out of the town i guess
like to the to the edges and they're
still [ __ ] there there's like a you
know
only whites only clan church so if he
wanted to prove something maybe he
should have gone wandering through the
outskirts no he did he did he did and he
like literally talked to a guy who was a
klansman who straight up tells him like
he's a neighbor of the grand wizard and
he's like oh you can't come to the you
know because he was like actually trying
to go and and find
the the main guy the grand wizard right
which i gave him props for i thought
that was like pretty brave of him as a
as a as a black man to like actually put
himself in harm's way like legitimate
harms yeah i'm not talking like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um and he did that and then he talked to
a guy who was like i'ma say i'm not a
segregationist i'm a separationist and
all this stuff and it was basically like
you know it was a civil discussion
and in that process while i was
describing these uh certain racial
concepts to my chat to my audience as is
what i do i'm a political commentator
gideon took personal offense to that and
thought i was like patronizing him and
telling him like he doesn't know what
racism is as a black man and he said
like i was like you know
it's giving white savior vibes which
you'll see in the video all right let's
watch
kids in the town were fans of gideon
they invited him to this kids in this
town liked him
this is unbelievable racism is over
people yeah of course of course well
that's
yeah because you know
a lot of the uh
reactionary conservatives will they like
to
one of their main talking points is that
there's no racism uh you know racism
doesn't exist anymore yeah of course as
proven by kids like the black man yeah
like what what the [ __ ] of course
rally around gideon so like
when you watch this video you gotta
applaud gideon for getting the results
that he got which were all positive and
not necessarily racist but you know who
had a big problem with uh you know
gideon ending racism
hassan [ __ ] now if you don't know
hassan piker's like gideon ended racism
sounded like it the kids loved him yeah
the kids in that town i mean but that's
the thing like of course they do and
that's normal and that's a good thing
right like
i think when you're
like this issue is so much more complex
than just like the kids were supposed to
be racist to him like what the [ __ ] do
you mean of course they're not going to
be that's not how racism works it's not
how systemic racism works you know right
yeah it's a good thing no it's it's
super disingenuous to frame it like that
and like i said that's one of their
that's one of their
they they need to convince white people
especially conservatives that they're
not racist and this is one way to do it
yeah no the only racism is like when you
say the n word like that's the only time
someone could be racist but even then
it's like well was it situational was it
contextually appropriate hypothetically
who knows you know maybe i was reading
tom sawyer huckleberry finn
like
okay
right and so you know he's always trying
to be the savior of black people and
whatnot i personally always got the
feeling that hassan wants bad stuff to
happen to black people so then he can
defend black people and look like i love
that guy that's a huge thing to put on
you oh no i always had the idea based on
nothing that his son's praying for bad
things that happened for black people so
that he can defend them yeah that's a
lot no
yeah
it's that was when i first watched it
yesterday i lost my mind that was
awesome that's an amazing analysis
that's the best thing he's ever said
he
it's it's just well you know what i'm
i'm praying for bad things to happen at
keemstar no i'm not i'm not i want only
i mean dude his life is living in hell
what do you mean he's [ __ ] keemstar
no no not not because i want bad things
but just so that i can defend him yeah
when it happened okay well well i'll
tell you let me tell you even yeah life
is his life is hell like it's anguish
every morning he wakes up it's like what
are you talking about he's dating a hot
[ __ ] 19 year old girl bro
that's what i'm saying it's like the the
insecurities that he will never be able
to his daughter and girl for almost the
same age that's [ __ ] sick yeah um but
this is pretty pretty basic republican
reactionary propaganda which is like oh
these leftists like they can't
want nice things for for people that uh
you know for for people outside of their
immediate demographic like it's
projection he literally thinks like
there needs to be a financial
compensation for like uh you know your
advocacy like the only reason why anyone
would ever defend black people and like
point out systemic injustice is
obviously if you're making a lot of
money it's like [ __ ] i've been
getting death threats for the past 10
years my entire family's been getting
destroys for the past [ __ ] 10 years
from
your friends and like neo-nazis and [ __ ]
which are keemstar's friends for this
kind of advocacy way before i like
actually became a financially successful
person you know what i mean and my life
would probably be the hitler
it would just be my life probably be
significantly easier if i just like did
reactions to tv shows and whatever and
like cut youtube especially
on uh charlie demilia's new boyfriend
yeah like if i did t-shit and and i
don't
because i truly believe in the things
i'm saying i just like it's kind of a
self-report
when he's like the only keemstar is
always self-reporting because his
worldview is so [ __ ] jaded and [ __ ]
up yeah he goes the only reason anyone
i'm secretly wishing for terrible things
to happen to the people i apparently say
i like just so that i'll have content i
mean that's [ __ ] great like to even
think of that but that's what he does
very much isn't that like literally what
he did he like voted
into uh into like you know
really horrible things that happened to
ethica like he did that yeah he was
trying to desperately create contact was
in the midst of a
complete mental breakdown like a bipolar
psychosis
and keemstar
was saying stuff like well
if nothing's real why don't you jump off
a bridge and stuff like that and he did
and he actually did eventually that's
right in the video he recorded by the
way
he mentions keemstar his uh goodbye
video when he's on his way to the bridge
he mentions keemstar that's what i mean
i don't like talking about it too much
but like it's just i mean he's a gross
person obviously like we're making jokes
right now and like i love
you know i i do find him a fascinating
character because you know he's just
fascinating like hitler is you know he's
like yeah he just he's fascinating he's
like i i'm always in awe that like a
person can like really up the ante with
how [ __ ] disgusting they can be you
know what i mean and suffer zero
repercussions for it so you know good on
him
but uh pretty funny i do love that he
was like you know the guy most famous
for like saying the n-word
and you know being a trump supporter and
[ __ ] is like
i
hassan is the real racist we got him
even though he's raising money and
advocating all the time and totally
consistent with his beliefs yeah he's
doing it
because he doesn't care about them
incredible that's why i do yeah exactly
it was it was
oh [ __ ]
sorry yeah click back my yeah i always
laugh at that but when people are like
dude you're such a grifter it's like bro
if i was a grifter i'd just be a [ __ ]
right winger it's like so much easier
dude i wish i was the right one grifter
bro i'd be selling supplements
it's just so much easier there's so much
less it's such such little scrutiny from
your fan base and audience if you're
right they love it
just keep saying the things that i agree
with and you don't even have to think
about it dude you just literally fall i
know
you just have to follow the script it's
like they write the they write the
thoughts for you it's awesome yeah you
get talking points the beard matches the
hood okay interesting
that's true well technically it does
matter they do match yeah do you think i
hate jewish people i want to know yeah
actually yes because one time
he went to he was streaming and he said
everybody go to ethan on twitter and
type
death to all jews to him
that's pretty well jews
but like it is fascinating that he just
like has no
like he's never been held accountable
like you have to admit it's like at a
certain point you're like damn like well
anyone that really is proof that you
know you could just get away with
anything
yeah pretty much
hates the jews i don't think any creator
has single-handedly done
what he did to etica and also basher's
another guy he bullied to the verge of
uh
being unaliving and eventually he
unfortunately died of kovid and keemstar
was like tap dancing on his grave bro it
was not who that is
he was a big minecraft youtuber
no and keemstar did this whole
it's a long story but it's really
interesting if you want to look into it
but yeah can't wait to report your death
and he said that the total biscuit when
he got diagnosed with cancer i mean he's
he's vile yeah but anyway here he is
pretty gross so but like a gross
star actually
raises is pretty funny you know what i
mean
so clan star here what is the
significance of the black hood i don't
know i think it's like different power
levels probably i think
yeah i don't know because some of the
some of the grand wizards like they wear
like purple and [ __ ] yeah they get real
they get really buoyant yeah they they
get real dressy with it um like a nice
whole like d system going on yeah like
levels and okay classes
that's great though because it's like it
doubles that don't cap for keem
not very smart well anyway clan star
goes on and says
he didn't really get a lot of hate he
didn't get a lot of racism he actually
talked to people
what like
so basically the irony there though is
like i'm literally describing like
that's not how racism works to my
audience right like i'm as is my job
uh that raises them a systemic and like
you can it's not going to be like right
in your face but to a reactionary person
they hear that and they go oh it's
because there wasn't any racism even
though like which means that there is no
racism in that town he's upset and he's
trying to like defend it by saying no no
it's actually racist well they they the
thing is when they go like that they all
it also informs policy they say we don't
need all these uh
inner city uh funding we don't need
to care about what goes on in
in like these urban black neighborhoods
because uh there's racism is dead and uh
it's all their fault and whatever is
going on with them i mean they literally
did say that the mayor that he talked to
actually had a facebook post talking
specifically about that he's like there
was nothing there was no problems in
this town until they came with that blm
sign like right you know what i mean we
have no police brutality here like and
it's a small town like i get it i'm sure
it's not as like
i think liberals also have a way of like
really exaggerating situations like
there's that attitude that liberals have
where they're like oh you're in a red
state well like [ __ ] you you know you
deserve it and it's like no there's
plenty of [ __ ]
first of all it doesn't even matter if
people have voted for democrat or
republican in any state ultimately you
should care for them by the virtue that
they are you know your fellow citizens
they're human beings and that's why i
believe in universal programs
but secondly people often forget like
there are millions of democratic voters
and liberals living in those areas as
well like of course there are plenty of
people who are not racist and and
liberals can be raised as well for the
record which judy had mentioned and i do
agree with that um they're just more
polite about it
but uh
you know i just that's but that's what i
was doing i was describing this and this
is what i do all right well let's see
fans of gideon they invited him to the
school they had a player
so like
when you watch this video you gotta
applaud gideon for getting the results
that he got which were all positive and
not necessarily racist but you know who
had a big problem with uh you know yeah
yeah ending racism i i accidentally
skipped back no okay all right hassan
[ __ ] now if you don't know hassan [ __ ]
is like he's like this political guy
right and so
he's trying to be the savior of black
people and whatnot i personally always
got the feeling that hassan
wants bad stuff to happen to black
people so then he can
defend black people and look like the
good guy and that helps him and that
helps his like political buddies so
hassan [ __ ] reacted to this video from
gideon and then gideon reacted to his
son [ __ ] this is so bad i mean when
hassan is really into this he's so horny
upset basically because they're not
being racist towards jillian's not what
happened
well anyone with a brain is clearly
understand it as well that's not how
racism were like even leading into this
that was my first thought is like well
that's not that doesn't prove that like
racism doesn't exist or something i mean
it's nice right like you said you like
we already said
so the thing is like that she's gonna
make him all so hard i was hoping he
would react to it so one thing that we
need to always wait what did you say
maul this she's gonna make you mauled so
hard i'm reading someone's comment
saying oh okay someone was saying like
this is gonna make you mad like this is
gonna upset you when you see it because
like there's a little bit of
whitewashing going okay okay okay i see
like a little bit of sanitation
happening there right is that like just
because i'm town is racist
one doesn't mean that they're going to
be like literally uh running around like
being running around and doing hate
crimes every black person right i don't
know why americans have such a twisted
and understanding of what racism is
which is weird i mean i know gideon
doesn't give a [ __ ] because he's like
you know he's a content creator first
like that's what i mean no i do give a
[ __ ] because you know first i'm a black
man first thing i do
i do care and then second thing
i don't have a skewed perception of what
racing sir are you wearing a shirt that
says professional raw dog i mean he's a
troll like he's so him just like trying
to get serious about this is like pretty
funny but
like a dude
what's the argument then like so you
were actually like that was me being
like you know he doesn't care he's just
like trying to make content and he's
like no i actually i i literally wanted
to defend the clansmen like what the
[ __ ] are you hold on man hold on
i could see the way you
said it or at least the way where he
paused and reacted to it
without seeing the full con i can
understand why he got a little defensive
there it sounds like you're saying he
doesn't care about it sounds like you're
saying he doesn't care about what's
actually happening there maybe that is
what you're saying no i'm saying that
like
he's
look
black white doesn't matter it's bigger
than black and white in the situation
like he he is not like he's not going in
there to to
i think make uh
to cut a message one way or the other
that was actually me being uh positive
and like giving him offering a saving
grace in that circumstance and be like i
don't think he has an agenda there to
like be like no this town is actually
not racist at all or this town is
actually super racist you know what i
mean and
if you go in there and you're just like
experiencing it obviously they're not
going to be like [ __ ] super racist to
your face like no i agree with that yeah
and by the way that that doesn't even
mean like
like he already correctly points out
that like liberals will sometimes be
like even more racist than republicans
and he's 100 correct in that like
they're just super polite about it but
if you understand that like liberals
like republicans will be racist to your
face and liberals will be polite but
then race is behind your back it's like
if you get that then how do you not
recognize that like the people that
you're talking to might also have that
same kind of attitude not saying that
these people do though like i'm not even
[ __ ] on this [ __ ] random tiny ass
i just saying it seems like it just
seems like i understand him being a
little defensive there maybe he's like
you know he's a content creator first
like that's what i mean no i do give a
[ __ ] because you know
first i'm a black man first thing i do
i do care because this is the same thing
this makes it seem like he like cared
and wanted to like make uh you know
sounds like you said look good it sounds
like you said he doesn't care if the
people there are racists or not
the way he paused it and so he's saying
i do care of the people there
because i'm black
i don't have a perception of what racism
is i've been black 21 years of my life
i've been black 21 years of my life i
know what racism is i know the different
forms that it comes in and stuff like
that
yeah i mean this is just unbelievable is
that it
no there's more there's more he like he
like watched the whole thing uh there's
like a part that's gonna come up in a
second that's like super clipped out of
context like i don't know if keemstar
did that deliberately or not but i was
like reading a chatter who says uh
you'll see you just play it just play it
and all right so so far it just seems
like you guys are
i don't think anything really happened
uh
at all gideon breaks down like hassan
patronizing him and treating him like
he's sub human and that you know he
needs hassan's protection from racism by
the way watch this wait although this is
the funniest part but by the way because
it's like
i think it's a self-report the way that
like conservatives talk about black
people or like how liberals are handling
black people is always like a weird
[ __ ]
it's always like very militant like he's
using certain terminology that i would
never [ __ ] use you know what i mean
uh like he's treating him like he's sub
human i'm like yeah that book that's
dramatic it's so like uh the the quarter
pounder tweet comes to mind you know
what i'm talking about where he's like
or or you know whenever the the
republicans will say like oh they're
trying to they're trying to you know get
people off the democratic plantation
it's like these are these are like very
uh i mean there's a microaggression
trapped inside of that [ __ ] sentiment
uh if you're incredibly comfortable
utilizing language like that one
description i agree i mean
what the like that's such a dramatic way
to describe it
reminder black people uh some people
think you're sub-human
that's what that's he went over there
like that's what he said yeah there's
something there right which for the
record like
gideon i don't know what his uh genuine
perspective is maybe he feels this way
maybe he doesn't right because he was
like hyping up keemstar a little bit
no this this is it's the keemstar cycle
yeah he was like oh man thank god you
know keemstar because keemstar was like
doing it in a very good way where he was
like gassing him you know what i mean he
was like oh yeah julian's actually
brilliant like you know yeah that as th
exactly as i said magidian will realize
someday
that keemstar is a [ __ ] trash person
oh sure all right let's keep it going
this is how i personally feel this is
how i feel like bro like this isn't like
factor this is all opinion this is how i
feel what you're saying to me
is
i don't understand basically what's
going on in this situation
that i just had this this was a 45
minute conversation that we cut down
that in this 45 minute conversation i
have no idea what was happening and
stuff like that and i need to relook
everything that's that's basically what
i'm hearing i'm feeling very patronized
i'm feeling very patronized and stuff
like that and i'm not gonna lie what
does a girl say it's given like bro it's
giving white savior vibes i'm sorry like
i it is giving white savior vibes and
stuff like that bro bro i don't need
anybody to save me i don't need any race
to save me stuff like that i think he's
just getting a little defensive he's
he's only 21. he made this video i think
he wanted to buy it guys i think he like
i'm not going to like armchair
psychology this i am even though i'm
doing that right now like i'd love to
talk to him about it personally which we
will eventually
um but i think he wanted to do something
like nice and more serious
but like right now the conversation he's
talking about is like him literally
talking to a klansman and the attitude
that you get out of that with the with
the conversation with the klansmen it
doesn't actually end up
it doesn't actually end up leaving uh
you with the with the notion that like
that klansman was uh a bad person and a
racist which is kind of what i was
pointing to and i think like you can use
that as a jump off point to make much
larger arguments about how white
supremacists have historically been able
to sanitize their movements and make
themselves more appealing to the larger
audiences uh and and that's that was my
main point and i think he is
loki uh getting defensive about this and
making that
uh undermining that point that i think
is is 100
without a doubt regardless of his own
personal feelings on the matter true
the guy he's talking about is literally
like i'm i'm a separationist like you
can't come to our white church yeah you
know what i mean like come on
and i think he agrees with me i think
there's a little bit of miscommunication
happening that's what i think too you
know i don't think he's defending the
[ __ ] kkk guy like i doubt it
but there is the
yeah i think he's just getting defensive
he's like i made this thing you're
criticizing it when everybody loves it
white savior i don't even know what i
liked it too i love the conversation
with the [ __ ] klansmen like that's
the thing that's my [ __ ] i love that i
do that stuff all the time i went to a q
a on rally like i i go to i love
watching republicans operate in their
own environment naturally like i'm i'm
fascinated so
i actually did like that part andrew's a
good friend of mine channel 5 he does
this
literally all the time
and and we love his work uh on my
broadcast in my community
and you know i i thought that this was
you know there was really interesting
and entertaining parts through it but
i'm always going to [ __ ]
uh you know
use any of these uh kinds of
opportunities
to cover a broader message when
educating my community on this kind of
[ __ ] cause like there's a lot of there's
like i'm not speaking to jitty and
personally when i talk about this i'm
speaking to my community and there might
be young people in there there might be
like people at the precipice of like
being kind of racist but like unlearning
that sort of behavior in there i that's
what i care about i care about changing
their minds
let's see what kimchi is the only person
i need to say me is the most high that's
it that's the only person i need to have
my back and stuff like that i don't need
a white savior i don't need a black
savior i just need me myself and i and
the most high other than that i'm good
and stuff like that and for you to
interject your opinion thinking that i
don't understand what's going on and
that
um just because you know he wasn't being
racist to my face that he's gonna be
violently if he was gonna be racist he
said violently racist how he's gonna be
violently racist behind my back
what the [ __ ] is he gonna do behind my
back so this is the this is the
miscommunication here i said virulently
and violently racist when i was
referencing the clan like the dude's a
klansmen and the clan is a history of
being violently and violently racist so
just because that one particular person
was like nice to you when having a
conversation with cameras on doesn't
change the reality that like
you know
like they wait he's defending the clans
man yeah he's literally defending him
now and i don't even know if he's like
that was his intention i'm being as
charitable as i humanly possibly can
here i don't think he was like intending
to defend the klansmen there in the
combo that he's having but i think
that's how it's coming across
uh and and uh you know keemstar this is
keemstar's framing of it this is not the
full video anyway and i think keemstar
is kind of doing him a disservice by
cutting it like this
well especially if you know the full
context you know keemstar understands
separatism because uh
he's like yeah dude because he he you
know
he is one right let's just be honest
i don't know why he's literally saying
like what if he was going to be racist
he would have been racist to me like to
my face and he but he was being racist
to his face he said you cannot come
tomorrow
especially not you like you can't come
to the [ __ ] white church like
and and talked about how he's a he's a
separationist and he actually ends up
saying like he wants to do israel he's
like and then and judy is like oh i
thought you guys didn't like jews he's
like no no we're the chosen people
oh they [ __ ] hate you my dude trust
me don't get them started on the jails
yeah he's like israel but like you know
no jews only us only the whites
he should have got the whole gang and
like kicked me off his property i was on
his yard
let me defend this klansman for a second
to go crazy he had every right could
have said it was self-defense and stuff
like that but no he came outside we had
a civil discussion boom
like that's why he's actually a really
good guy once you get to know him dude
that's what i'm saying no i don't know
like like we're memeing we're meaning
like i said i don't think i don't think
he like intended to come across like
he's defending the clansmen he is but he
is literally doing that
like but well you know there is one
klansman i like that is a really good
guy
keemstar actually
a clan star here like i don't know how
the [ __ ] we got back to like you know we
got to have a civil discussion with the
klansmen to understand where they're
coming from like bro
you know where they're coming from
you're black like what do you mean they
wanted actually i have a pla i have a
meeting plan with a nazi who a
really nice guy
he just thinks that i should uh be dead
but other than that really sweet like
their entire perspective is like
he's like that's the goal go back to
africa
he's succeeding though the klansmen is
succeeding when he says oh i'm a
separationist not a segregationist well
okay what was segregation it was
separate but equal you know what i mean
like
and if you're not recognizing that
what's going on there then it doesn't
matter what your personal background or
your personal uh you know the personal
violence that you might be subjected to
as a consequence of like that kind of
attitude manifesting throughout society
it doesn't matter because we're talking
about
uh what the what the
historical uh background of the clan is
and and how their
how klansmen will routinely [ __ ]
uh change their uh you know change their
messaging around uh the broader public
they know pr nazis know how to do pr
neo-nazis know how to do pr even the
most average [ __ ] small brained
incestuous klansmen knows how to do
[ __ ] good marketing for the clan
right that's what they're doing
right and they openly talk about that
too where it's like
you know you got to look good in the
media
once you yeah yeah exactly here let's
i'm not saying you're a racist or
nothing like that but what i'm saying is
like wait everything that you're saying
in this video and what your chat's
saying i feel is way more worse racially
motivated than anything he said
well
that's insane that's insane because he
doesn't he doesn't want to live he
doesn't want you to
he doesn't want to ever have to see you
he's uh bro he i mean that that's not
that's the thing you said that my
community is more racism than the
[ __ ] klansmen like he's talking to
that was a little wild like i said i
think you know tensions
dude but yeah i mean look there's a
problem here he's whitewashing the
[ __ ] clan i know but
no no i'm i'm saying that like look you
already assessed it correctly he's young
he's yeah exactly chad's probably saying
like yo what do you think about this guy
he's like clowning on you whatever yeah
he's gay yeah he's going defense mode
that's it
and anything that anybody in that town
did to me and stuff like that because
i feel like i'm being patronized and
when you're being patronized that means
you're not on that same level because
the people think that they're superior
like that's what i'm thinking that's
what i'm feeling look at how polite he
is by the way he's forming the local
teens into a gang yeah so that is from
my chat
so someone in my chat wrote like
i was talking about look how polite the
clansman is being
uh to him and then i read someone's chat
and you can see it in gideon's video
like i'm literally highlighting it in
the chat someone says look out uh
someone says like he's lo he's forming
the local teens into a gang hoggers
which is like an emote that we use to
identify sarcasm it's like a tone
indicator basically
and it was uh it was in lower case
though so it didn't come across like the
the emote but i'm reading someone's chat
and that person is joking about the
other klansman's perspective not saying
he's like you know creating he barely
showed what you said though i mean it
like makes no sense it's totally out of
context
just as much as conservative people are
rape people because yeah
i just want to see kids
the racism is like literally on the same
level and you ask anybody
he's right he's right about this though
he's right about this like liberals are
oh i thought he i i didn't watch that i
thought he was talking about the
clansman and you no no no no he he moves
on and basically says that like i'm a
liberal i'm very liberal which i'm not
but it's fine um americans only have
like two speeds on [ __ ] politics
which is
uh you know liberal or conservative
um
and he's basically he's basically like
misunderstanding that position and
saying like oh he's like a liberal
racist like look at him saying like he's
he's forming a gang which
out of context he's right like if i was
being like oh yeah look he is building a
gang
like just like black people do then yeah
he would be correct that would be his
assessment in that situation would be
absolutely correct i would be behaving
in a you know white savior liberal way
so i don't i don't fault him for
misunderstanding that position it's just
me reading chat people always
don't know what that dynamic looks like
on twitch black person like they will
tell you the same thing bro why can't
hassan
just acknowledge that gideon went to the
most racist town in america
and like there was progress people were
nice to him he was nice in return he was
respectful to them they were respectful
to him and he got good results why can't
you acknowledge that i mean jillian just
goes off on hassan he's like listen you
can dana you could donate all the money
to the black lives matter stuff and like
all this other stuff to help black
people but like
you're not gonna go face this racism
face to face like
like he did this he went to the town he
talked to people with no security you
know what you can donate all the money
yeah whatever you put my life in harm's
way quite frequently and unfortunately
it even extends to my family members
which is completely ridiculous and
unacceptable
so that's not true either
but also yes there is one part that is
completely correct i will never
experience the same level of vitriolic
racism that a black person will
experience whether it be in you know
arkansas or whether it be in [ __ ] los
angeles so if gd were to make that point
he's absolutely correct i will never
understand it personally i i will i will
i can only be empathetic to it okay so i
i recognize that that's true but well i
don't know keemstar is such a [ __ ] like
he barely shows anything you said
and just kind of paraphrases whatever he
thinks you said it's
black creators for your political agenda
you're pretty cool ladies and gentlemen
that's all the time we yeah he's
discussing that he's pretty gross where
he's just like basically saying i'm like
uh you know i'm i'm just using uh these
these you know why don't you just stop
talking about black people yeah okay
that's the goal it's it's literally just
like yeah just shut the [ __ ] up about uh
you know black issues
oh what's this classic keemstar
homophobia
is this safe to watch
uh as long as you don't let it continue
playing as long as you don't use the
audio god he used to look way more gross
honestly yeah no he lost a lot of weight
yeah i don't know how it's possible
and trying to he looks like a [ __ ] yeah
no i mean he used to look like this for
a long time but
straight villain dude
straight villain i just had to pull it
because of his uh misspelling of racist
and it reminded me of when he uh called
people homophobic hobophobic yeah
it was right at the beginning of that
clip wait i never i didn't see the hobo
phone there on the trick shot community
many of these teams are big they have
lots of sponsors and at the same time
they're being racist homophobic no he
did not say
why don't we have that soundbite
that's all i didn't remember until i saw
the race hobo
this is this is a man who's going to
murder and cook you
look at that face
like
i do appreciate it when when you know
dudes just like
when they look the part of how [ __ ]
villainous they are on this yeah
exterior matches the yeah the interior
all right well we're low on time so
let's just pick out
some of the good ones here
um
yeah we probably have time to do one
maybe two of like these uh segment
segments so whichever one seems most
interesting oh love gave me some insight
it's possible he misspelled it on
purpose so it didn't get yellowed
well he didn't misspell it in the title
only the thumbnail so i don't think
that's the case
same with races too like he misspelled
raises in the [ __ ] thumbnail and then
didn't even change it so i don't know
what
dude that dude said hobophobic
well because somebody actually did that
once yeah
said hobophobic
no sorry we
misspelled it on purpose to keep it from
getting dinged because it got
demonstrated
that dumb that that actually works
yes yes it worked interesting
yeah those dang grasses jurassic
we should probably do the left camp meme
thing since that is the title of the
episode currently i think we should do a
keemstar title but what was what's the
uh what which one we have jack pro
subiac pro uh probiotic
i mean that's pretty good too
and we have
uh
you don't want to talk about probiotic
no i don't have a problem with talking
about probiotic no the other one was the
the nazi dude
wait which one
oh is he is that who he's the
referencing dude i'll talk about
whatever i don't remember wait wait wait
what not what was the other story the
other one was the left camp meme is the
oh we should talk about that i love that
one okay let's talk about that so wait
where the [ __ ] down at the bottom
scroll down
okay this guy
so benny johnson
uh he's a he's actually a famous
plagiarist yeah an all-around dumbass
buzzfeed andy over here yeah uh
so
this guy first of all
what's feminine baked alaska too not not
great
not a great track record for those boys
over there so i guess parlor hired him
to make an exclusive show called
the left camp meme
dude this is so awesome which by the way
there's a huge community called the
right cam or meme
so he's already plagiarized the idea
and the the uh
the execution is so [ __ ] bad every
meme
is just this girl from like what 2015
like they have not moved past
this screaming contra points
made a really good point the other day
when she was like
this woman was like correct
and and actually like foresaw how
horrifying the the upcoming next like 10
years
nailed it but i just think it's so funny
like they have not found a better meme
like this girl is just the
people's
i can't believe this shit's real and
look at this [ __ ] goon so it just
revolves around like my enemies are ugly
and uh we are somehow hot but like
they're not so i don't know like you
literally look like that person all the
time you know what i mean you look
you look way worse than that person when
you're not even doing a face
so what the [ __ ] is your point
so this guy benny johnson made this he
was fired from buzzfeed for plagiarizing
apparently buzzfeed found 41 instances
of plagiarism in his writings
comprising of 10 of his work and he was
fired and had to apologize
so all around good guy the idea is
plagiarized uh he's also the chief
creative officer at charlie kirk's
turning point usa
also known as toilet paper usa yeah
those guys are really good they make
great memes but like unintentionally
like the the best memes that come out of
like toilet paper usa is oftentimes just
people dunking on them
i love toilet paper usa and again that
just proves what we all know which is
the right camp meme they have no sense
of humor
dude name one funny
conservative
or like political commentary person like
think of like crowder is that the best
they've got reuben
reuben is hilarious i'll give you that
funny
pretty phony um so here's the show guys
exclusively at poller parlor so well
exclusively at the hassan i'll be
broadcast because i'll be [ __ ]
watching the [ __ ] out of this like every
time new episodes come oh yeah
yeah exactly exclusively [ __ ] nowhere
when i see stuff like this i'm like a
gift thank you yeah i don't know why you
did this for me but thank you you work
in mysterious ways well when i saw this
guy i was like this guy's [ __ ] done
this guy's roasted i
yeah i hope not i'm praying that he's
not done well hopefully i don't i doubt
they're paying him much
oh no they they got deep pockets over
there like
a lot of these initiatives a lot of
these initiatives are just like backed
by
like these bloodthirsty freak billions
there's like two
two or four milligrams i have a four
milligram and a two milligrams give me a
four let me see if i can handle no it's
gonna [ __ ] you no dude you're gonna
[ __ ] poop your pants give me the
floor it'll be interesting okay we gotta
we gotta spice it up bro there you go
bro they look dark and yellow like holy
[ __ ] that's gonna burn my it's gonna be
that the four milligrams like not even
good it doesn't even taste good you
don't like the four
um i swap in and out does it give you a
rush
no
when do you decide if it's time for a
two or a four
i have a four
after meals usually okay get that little
get that extra little uh-huh and that's
it
so
so right now you're chewing it too no
i'm just shooting a regular gum right
now
so you're always chewing yeah
you have regular gum two and four you
have a whole regiment interesting yeah
oh that textures what the [ __ ] is this i
told you yo there's really good ones
this one's off the neck the knickers
that i have yeah this is nicorette it's
terrible but it has a it has a flavor
this is just wax yeah this is the worst
gum i've had in my life it's flavorless
wow it's bitter it's bitter it's nasty i
hate it
why don't you get a different gum well i
i uh ordered it and this was the wrong
one it was the wrong flavor so i'm not
gonna throw it out it's like [ __ ]
expensive
this is it this is awful
i
i told you i didn't expect it though i'm
[ __ ] i literally told you okay
but anything it doesn't even have flavor
i mean put some [ __ ] spearmint in it
uh i know that one is like really bad
that one's flavorless all right i'm
gonna hit this up i'll let you know if
i'm about to pass out or [ __ ]
that's where i put it yeah
rock and roll baby oh yeah
all right let's watch this [ __ ] goon
this [ __ ]
[Music]
my name is benny johnson and welcome to
the
just look at his background right off
the bat dude he's such a child
he's just like elon musk [ __ ] rules
and this girl from 2015
she's [ __ ] suck
how are you gonna [ __ ] meme about
elon musk and not put up the local
legend uh elon ma from china have you
guys seen that now that that guy's
awesome that [ __ ] lives in my
mind dude in my heart i think wait i
gotta out you a little bit you thought
he was that was really his face
is that a deep fake of course it is i
don't want to believe it it's a deal
it is i refuse to believe there's a deep
fake i i would i have to admit i also
was unsure at first i've been bro
there's a lot of better than i was like
okay i can definitely see that but
there's a lot of people in china they
had a seven foot
that looks like elon musk
i wish but it's a deep fake i don't want
to believe it
it's literally his face
yeah
it's perfect it's a younger no no pull
up the video pull up the video you can
really tell
i would love to see them
like maybe just have a call
yeah
is that what he goes back
musk
he long map dude i love him i love him
so much
i love his videos because he he doesn't
really go with a plan you know no he's
just like yeah he's just like living his
life dude he's like i look like elon
musk
i'd like to meet this guy if he is real
hard to tell with defects these days so
even elon got
to come up that's so [ __ ] funny but
no that's not that's yes it is dude elon
musk with a better hairline
china number one once that's done
if that's right by the way first of all
the thought of this being real
is so funny i understand being motivated
personally by my interest like i want
him to be real
i get that i'm a little biased i get
that like it's exciting but here here's
a video
[Music]
that's a deep fake dude sorry wait you
gotta hear it though we gotta hear what
he's saying no there's copyrighted music
he's awesome
you can tell it's a defect this just
looks artificial it doesn't look like a
deep fake it looks real the way the eyes
blink and the math moves it's clearly a
deep fake it's so perfect though like it
literally just like looks like his
mannerisms well
the defects are insane you saw
kendrick's new music video yeah that was
i mean
except for the kind of one that was a
little
they they didn't do them justice on that
one yeah but everyone else's defense
looked really good
the best one is the fake tom cruise guy
on tick tock oh yeah that guy too that
guy's freaky yeah but do you know what
i'm saying you can you can kind of tell
pattinson
there's robert pattinson at home like
is it walmart version it's like really
funny his hairline's like kind of
scuffed
anyway shout out to him though i love
the dedication love the whole persona
genius
anyway back to this [ __ ] game way
cooler than elon musk so yeah bro that
guy oh yeah i'd way rather get [ __ ]
lunch with him elon musk 100
world exclusive premiere of the left
can't meme ladies and gentlemen an
exclusive series on parlor parlor where
free speech
lives and champion in the form this is
like the dog [ __ ] is [ __ ]
[ __ ] here [ __ ] oh my god
memes and content that we're going to be
highlighting on our ship
is that the stupid thing with with the
heads you know going like this you
remember that yeah yeah i'm like this is
jim jeb you're right well the market
audience like the last time they could
[ __ ] actually you know form a new
memory was when jib jab was around so
so they're like you know they're
tailoring it to that to those people the
memes we will show you on today's
episode would get you banned on social
media why do a show on memes uh no these
memes are so good they would get you
banned on social media it's like dude
what are you talking about what calling
[ __ ] brian still a potato i've called
him way worse [ __ ] than that you know
what i mean like oh no they they love
this idea that you can't say anything on
twitter man i see the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
on twitter y'all crazy yeah dude you
have to be a real degenerate to get
banned on twitter like it is not easy
yeah it's awesome no they just like mean
like they can't personally and
individually harass people i think i get
twitch from people being like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you you jewish piece of
[ __ ] yeah and then i report it and
twitter's like
uh
uh thank you for reporting it we didn't
notice any violation in this but feel
free to block that person yeah okay
i'm like okay no violation thank you
thank you for the suggestion on like the
11th soccer account that this person has
made i was like you read that you read
that
violation specifically harass me in my
replies like and
yeah no it's great thank you yeah i know
for sure each lives and is champion in
the form of hilarious memes and content
that we are going to be highlighting on
our show so
this is
this must be like a 10 year old meme by
the way
now many of the memes we will show you
on today's episode would get you banned
on social media while you show on memes
because the memes hurt their feelings
are first
that's such a big rep self-reporter
there why are we showing you the memes
not for laughter but because it hurts
their we might always be attacking the
libs dude that's awesome dude you're a
grown-ass man bro what the [ __ ] are you
doing
the left can't meme the memes of the
weak very important musk memes so hot
right now and bro just stop you gotta
turn
i can't deal with this
no embrace it embrace it this is
actually
this is like destroying uh cultural
norms is it this is the cultural
revolution for conservatives like he's
literally saying like no actually we are
going to we are going to do a return
to you know the the nine gag era of
memes like we're gonna do that whether
you like it or not
i respect it i respect that dying gag
this is like
i don't even know yeah i mean
2 000 no everything is like
everything is so old there's no fresh
content i'd like to see what episode
three is going to look like dude or
episode 10. dude it's awesome keep going
keep it going let it ride are you saying
something in oh i was gonna say yes as
somebody that makes a lot of memes and
photo edits for the show i hate it and i
kind of this i can't believe this is a
show and please this makes me want to
never edit a photo again
we need you cam but thank you for
sharing
this is the worst concept for a show and
i make memes all the time for this show
you know so well because they like
transparently are trying to make the
memes themselves instead of like finding
them and it completely obviously
destroys the entire purpose of like
uh how memes happen or or how they like
the organic nature of how you you you
know create uh commentary around a
subject matter that everyone is like in
agreement on um
in a tiny little frame next to next to
the swedish homies oh that's that's
correct yeah that's
okay oh yeah he's a simp he's number one
he's a tier three sub she's just gone
she actually responded to him on twitter
a few days ago is that right left well
that's right it's pretty big dude not
weird at all
that's
you know
i started off as a fan you know and then
someone's at the office saw it and
apparently i'm a sim for just watching
her i i think that's an issue personally
he talks about her yeah
it's kind of a meme because people were
calling him a simp and so now he's like
embrace the meaning oh okay i think love
knows that one day they'll be together
in a healthy way in the healthiest way
possible that's not true
goddamn rasco you know they are soul
mates she just didn't realize it yet
okay
all right let's watch people at twitter
are like i feel like i'm taking crazy
pals i feel like i'm taking crazy pills
oh wow they were like they're
referencing at work here's the libs
being fired off like rockets
these people are not even
come on dude he's literally describing
the [ __ ] meme in front of your face
like what the [ __ ] these are as you can
see here uh these are you know the libs
being fired off as rockets like bro are
you he's literally explaining something
that like does not need an explanation
zoolander came out in 20
2001 by the way
these aren't even like prominent people
like again taylor lorenz is like
you know well she's been making the
rounds now but like again dude you can't
have this girl in every [ __ ] this
like you've got to get new jokes is that
the same girl yes it's the same girl and
every [ __ ] man what about the one on
the like to the left of her is that also
the same girl like who are these i think
i've seen that one yeah yeah yeah
it's always funny very good
it's her again yep her again
[Music]
elon when he laughs he's life
laughs his life is in so much here she
is again
ah this is the same girl dude it's this
is awesome i love this i love this so
much because like
you can see the anguish like he is in so
much pain this literally is like filmed
like there's a guy with a gun
pointed uh pointed directly at his head
uh right right off camera like he's like
ah this is so funny please i've been
trapped in this mental prison of my own
making for many many years please save
me end it all
actually don't even know what the joke
is that he's planting
having to fake laugh at like dog [ __ ]
memes that even you with your dog [ __ ]
brain have recognized as dog [ __ ] is
like the perfect [ __ ]
monkey's paw type situation for benny
johnson like you can tell he's like
rocket sounds
this is so funny
he will think he will on alive by like
the fourth episode if he keeps this up i
don't see how that works yeah i don't
see how it's going to last yeah
lives in the fields what's funny about
that like genuinely he's laughing but i
don't even get it i dude you don't dude
what's funny
he's planting lips in the field or maybe
it's he's harvesting he's harvesting
the blue check mark
i guess dude see you know
comedy it's not even worthy of a cackle
i mean it's even it's all low brow
diabetes humor with you i see this
[ __ ] same girl lives in the fields
liz just want to date elon musk
this is so good
her again
dude you can't do like you have to prove
that this is a real thing because you
found one person no i mean but like it's
over like they they got him you know
what i mean libs are all they've been
using the same girl for like 20 years
here's elon
sweeping people out of the the temple
that is twitter
but
by the way you know he's seen all these
before there's no [ __ ] shot he thinks
any of these are funny yeah uh
you're wrong he's clearly laughing
twitter's top lawyers staff cries during
meeting about must take over okay but
like
whoa i've never seen this image before
look they're all her the girl from 20
years ago
let him have this dude i think let him
have it i i'm gonna give it to the
conservatives like no one's gonna watch
this anyway no this image is so funny
that anytime you use it it's hilarious
yeah can i ask the show is called the
left can't meme
but
evidently the premise of the show is to
just review right-wing memes that he
liked like wouldn't it made more sense
if he was looking at shitty left memes
that is the mind of the reactionary you
you've like a reactionary cannot
uh cannot even showcase like their own
uh humor without somehow making it
oppositional like it has to be in
opposition to the left the left can't
meme the right can
just say the right can meme no he's not
going to say that he's going to say the
law the whole premise is plagiarized
again from actual funny people
yeah they make fun of me well the the
left camp meme was like the original
it was actually originally like the
4chan uh take which was like
you know when when you know that nazis
was like popping off and they were like
groipers and pepe the frog was like seen
as like a nazi symbol or whatever um
that's what they were saying like the
left can't meme and like the memes our
memes actually ended up like making
donald trump the president like that's
what 4chan literally [ __ ] thought
uh and now it's just all like well
divorced ads on there like it's it's no
longer the the hot spot for
the teenagers they've moved on from it
so
we're just trying to capture that
essence once again like this is the you
know what this is
this is for uh this is like
the glory days reliving the glory days
like high school of a high school
quarterback trying to constantly go back
to that and capture the essence of that
[ __ ] moment where they peaked but
even way more pathetic than that because
like you're literally trying to capture
the essence of like what when you peaked
as a memeer yeah like that's we haven't
seen any pepe frog memes yet but i'm
sure they're coming next episode
twitter's top lawyer reassures staff
cries during meeting about musk takeover
elon musk the netflix
special
elon
[Laughter]
that was not bad very very good always
like
black face
make twitter great again elon musk is
donald trump very good photoshop shut
the [ __ ]
oh look who it is it's the same girl
from 20 years ago i'm moving to canada
i'm removing my music from spotify i'm
deleting my twitter account by the way
this has a watermark so he they're not
making these these are the best what i
mean to say
these are the best they've found yes
it's always the same thing
triggered rhapsody triggered a rhapsody
very good cleanliness
the triggered people screaming
bro this is awesome this is awesome
you're literally watching mental decay
first classic the reap
come on where would the meme world be
without the screaming live at donald
trump
where would it be
he's right
where would we be ladies and gentlemen
without the screaming lib
we got to have there she is
we love her folks
these memes will never die and the
screaming lib meme will never die one of
the most important memes in the world
one of the most important ways stop stop
he said one of the most important memes
in the world bro what the [ __ ] it's
memes dog what's wrong with you
you're an adult dude you're an adult oh
no that's so awesome
and then these guys are like you know
they talk about like how that the next
generation is a bunch of [ __ ] you
know unlike me a man who sits in a room
and is like this is the greatest name of
all time like you know i'm a clown and i
[ __ ] know that you know what it is a
twitch streamer and like i make fun of
myself regularly for stuff like this but
like
you're not going to catch me be like
this is the greatest most important meme
of all time
seriously
okay something wait what do we got here
what do you got cam
uh in the right screen graphic i don't
know if you guys noticed uh i edited his
face on that person's body and they look
the exact same
like it's the you know dead ringer this
is the rage face look he's doing the
troll face right now oh yeah you see his
mouth's all crisp
that's what he's doing he's saying
problem i don't know what you're talking
about cam like the uh on the screen
graphic here we'll we'll send it right
now we'll see what he's talking about he
looks exactly like the person that he's
making fun of let me see that's what i
was saying like the the homie doesn't
look like you know
not exactly peak masculinity over here
nope
look like on a fake laugh oh my god look
at this dude you drinking a little too
much soy in your shoes
wait this is from the show that's his
face yeah dude that's your face
that's your face you better change your
face if you're gonna keep doing the show
oh no
we need like liver king to host this
show or something we need like you know
what i'm saying
yeah but even liverpool's like better
adjusted than this [ __ ] guy you know
what i mean liver king here the left
camp meme let's get into it yeah
now out there just like the indigenous
tribes that i've uh you know
went on a hunt with uh laughter is the
best medicine they always say
now this person definitely doesn't eat
enough liver
yeah if they ate enough if they ate more
liver they would understand that donald
trump is the best president
um okay well let's let's uh and then the
re as the cause oh my god
it's just
it's just i mean it's just this girl
[Laughter]
bro it's like it's pretty wild can't
mean tune in every week your boy benny
will be meaning
oh yes yeah you have to you have to go
to you have to
you know what man at the end of the day
you got to sleep knowing with knowing
what you've done here no it's awesome
it's [ __ ] awesome benny so cool
what's his name benny what benny johnson
benny johnson who was fired from i mean
there's like so many cringe things that
he has done throughout his entire career
of just like being the absolute worst
but because conservatives have like the
greatest jobs program in their pundit so
true point of class that hillary
literally all prominent like uh media
personalities just fail upwards
consistently it's awesome
love my family god and pipe tobacco not
necessarily in that order yeah he loves
pipe tobacco more than family
uh his pin tweeted about elon musk that
must as he would reverse tom's
suspension well obviously i want i want
that to happen yeah i want to i want
trump at least like as horrifying of a
monster donald trump was like which is
not all that different than like the
rest of the republican party or you know
just politicians in general uh he was uh
just simply extending the logical
conclusion of like many of these like
uh attitudes that the republican party's
like been building for many many years
he was at least a good poster he was a
petty he was a great poster he was a
petty [ __ ]
and he was a great poster by the way
this is how he's the how old is benny
johnson this man has children look how
he's look how he words his tweets
desantis shuts down biden's creepy
minister of truth with brutally honest
take down he's 34.
he's only 34. i gotta say dude you gotta
cut down on the pipe yeah that was
actually shocking you gotta you gotta
cut down on the pipe smoke around 30. oh
no
it looks like that at 34. that's come on
benny and this is coming and look i
don't look great for my age some people
say i look older but
the way that you're approaching the meme
culture i thought you were figuring
conservatism is is a brain disease
straight up it advances aging
all right are we good to go because this
gum is making me i actually do need the
[ __ ] again
i took it out of my mouth
we are we are out of time so yes thank
you guys for watching i need to run to
the toilet i don't know hassan thank you
for being here as always
yes we love you hassan
catch us on on twitch you guys know what
it is always yeah you got any good
interviews coming up
um i had i i had felix peterman at
chopper trap house earlier i might have
day one uh on from chromio again uh this
week potentially uh i was supposed to do
a rolling stone interview tomorrow but i
don't know if that's gonna happen
there's a bunch of stuff always
happening on my streams
follow them on twitter every day follow
it we will prevail guys wants bad stuff
to happen to black people
well that's that's true yeah because
he nailed me on that i love that that
was so funny our opposition is the benny
johnson so guys we got a good shot out
here let's keep it up the ward the meme
wars have only just begun that's right
thanks for watching guys thank you asan
thank you everybody we'll see you
tomorrow it's friday baby and on
saturday members only live stream for
our boy ab he's going to knock him out
all right i got to go to the bathroom
all right
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you